[Musique]
euh
tout d'abord la grande majorité je
dirais 95
du jugement de ce juge était de faire droit
au dossier de l'accusation d'extradition
elle a refusé l'expédition au dernier
moment dans les derniers mots de son jugement
car elle a accepté que julian assange
était un risque suicidaire  et que s'il était
soumis
à des mesures administratives spéciales dans
le système pénitentiaire des États-Unis,
ce serait un acte oppressif et sur
cette base,
elle a refusé l'extradition tout d'abord,
les États-Unis vont faire appel de
cette décision
et donc la décision sera prise à un
je m'attends à ce
que nous devions mener ce
combat à nouveau, alors s'il
vous plaît, célébrez
[Musique]
que le système pénitentiaire américain
est si mauvais que même
ce juge n'y enverrait pas
Julian Assange
aujourd'hui, c'est une victoire pour Julian oui
oui  la victoire d'aujourd'hui est le premier pas
vers la justice dans cette affaire, nous sommes
heureux que le tribunal
ait reconnu la gravité et l'
inhumanité
de ce qu'il a enduré et de ce à quoi il est confronté  s
mais n'oublions pas que
l'acte d'accusation aux États-Unis n'a pas été
abandonné, nous sommes extrêmement préoccupés par le fait
que le gouvernement américain a décidé de faire
appel de cette décision,
il continue de vouloir punir Julian
et de le faire disparaître dans le trou le plus profond et le plus
sombre
du système carcéral américain pour  le reste de
sa vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]